The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK.
So this is lecture 22,
gradient and divergence,
headed for Laplace's equation.
So the gradient will
be our operator A;
the divergence, or
minus the divergence,
will be A transpose,
and then A transpose A
will be the Laplacian.
We get to Laplace's
equation Wednesday.
Today I wanted to
take them separately.
To understand the
meaning of gradient,
the meaning of divergence,
the connection between them.
I mentioned at the
end of last time
that one is the transpose of the
other, or minus the transpose.
I'll try to keep
gradient on this side,
and if I could only
transpose the blackboard,
I could do divergence-- I'll
do divergence on that side.
And I guess if I could
get a rotating blackboard,
right in the middle
I could do curl.
That would be
perfect. [LAUGHTER]
OK.
So some of this will
not be new to you.
But maybe some of the insights
or the ways of looking at it
could be new.
This is the background
of vector calculus.
So we have things
like vector fields.
That means I have a vector
[v 1, v 2] at each point (x,
y).
So I could draw a little
arrow at every point
to show the direction and
magnitude of that vector.
I have a field of vectors.
OK, so.
From last time,
our basic setup is,
the gradient is this
first operator, A. The one
we see at the beginning.
One change.
Instead of calling the result
e, let me connect to velocity.
I'll be thinking of
u as a potential,
I'll use the word potential for
u, and I'll use v instead of e
for the velocity component.
So that's the A.
And then on the other
side, I start with a w.
Again, it's a vector field,
it's actually a momentum.
Very often the step between
here and here, well most often,
the step between here and
here will be the identity.
That's what gives
Laplace's equation.
So you'll have to watch,
I'm sometimes confusing
the v's with the w's.
Because when I go to Laplace's
equation and c is the identity,
they're the same.
But I would like, today, to
try to keep this left side
separate, the gradient, from
the right side, the divergence.
And understand what they mean,
and how to work with them.
And of course, a big connection
is the divergence theorem,
or the Gauss-Green
connection, identity.
We'll get to that.
OK, gradient first.
First, what does it mean?
If I have a function u, what
does its gradient tell me?
And then the second is kind
of a backwards question.
Suppose I have the v. Is
it the gradient of some u?
So one direction from u to
v, and the second direction
will be from v back
to u when possible.
OK, meaning of the gradient.
So the gradient is
just the obvious thing,
the two derivatives in
the x and y direction.
So of course the gradient
gives you the rate of change,
the partial derivatives of u.
But how do you see
that in a picture?
Let me draw an important curve.
I'll start with a very simple u.
u is x squared plus y squared.
So that's my example.
Example one.
And what I've drawn is
an equipotential curve.
Or isopotential might be a more
appropriate word these days,
but we still say equipotential.
It means that, along this
curve, u is a constant.
And for this
particular potential,
this simple one to work with,
x squared plus y squared,
the curve is a circle.
So the curve would be a circle.
OK, now what do I learn
by taking the gradient?
So the gradient of u -- this
is my v -- is the x derivative,
which is 2x, and the y
derivative, which is 2y.
OK.
Let me take a typical
point on the curve
and draw that gradient vector.
So this is the xy-plane, this
is the curve u equal constant.
When I have a curve
u equal constant
and I draw the gradient
of u, where does it point?
This is the first
and most important
simple idea about
the gradient vector.
The gradient vector points--
Does the gradient vector point,
could it point any old way?
No.
The gradient vector is
perpendicular to the curve.
And we can see that,
for this simple example,
that vector [2x, 2y], that's
a vector radially outwards,
right?
If here's the origin,
and if, at this point --
I don't know its coordinates,
whatever they are, maybe (2,
1) or something -- the gradient
vector would be [4, 2].
It would be a multiple-- Here's
the position vector, [x, y].
The point is, the gradient
vector points out.
Perpendicular to the curve.
That's what the
gradient tells you.
It tells you, in
this situation it's
telling me which direction is
perpendicular to the curve.
Now how do I understand that?
How do I see that?
I think of this-- Let me try
to draw the whole surface,
u equal x plus y squared.
What would that whole
surface look like?
Let me try to put that picture--
This is a 2-D picture right
now.
It's sort of a cross-section.
Let me put this 2-D picture
into a 3-D picture to see.
So the 3-D picture is a
picture of the whole surface. u
going up, x and y going around.
And what kind of a curve,
what kind of a surface
do I have for that function,
x squared plus y squared?
Well, it grows, right?
It's sort of, I
use the word bowl.
And we've seen it before.
It sort of goes
up, right, and it
goes up faster and faster as I
go out, because of the squares.
And now what I want
to do is, suppose
I take the cross-section,
suppose I take this bowl.
Do you see a
beautiful bowl there?
And now, I cut through it,
horizontal cross-section,
at the height c.
What do I get if I take
this surface in 3-D,
and I cut through it by a plane,
the plane at that height, c.
So if the plane went through
there, that distance was c.
It cuts out a cross-section
out of the bowl.
And what's the cross-section?
It's the circle.
It's this one.
So out of the bowl, this plane
is cutting this cross-section.
This is height u equal constant.
So I'm really intersecting
one surface, the plane u
equal constant, with the bowl.
And the intersection of those
two is the equipotential,
the curve u=c.
Right?
You see the two pictures?
And now, what does the gradient
tell me in that picture?
What does the gradient of
u tell me in that picture?
Over here, it pointed
outwards, but now we're
going to kind of see why.
So, it pointed outwards
for this nice function u.
I could have made a
more general function u,
but let me just stay
with this simple one.
So suppose I'm climbing.
This is like, I'm climbing
out of a volcano or something.
Usually, I would say a
mountain, but the way
I've drawn the thing, it's
not much of a mountain.
So OK, volcano.
Climbing out of it.
And I got up to this point,
which was this point.
Now, what does the
gradient tell me?
That when I'm climbing away,
I reach -- duh duh duh duh --
I get up to here.
What does the gradient tell me?
It tells me which way to go.
It tells me the steepest
direction upwards,
and it tells me how steep.
Right.
So it tells me those two
things, direction and magnitude.
Direction is, well for
this special function
you know the direction is,
like, straight outwards,
straight upwards.
And how steep is it?
What's the steepness?
It's the size of, it's the
magnitude of this vector,
grad u.
Which is the-- This is not--
How big is this vector?
This is my vector grad u.
This is another shorthand
notation for gradient.
The size of that vector is
the square root of what?
The length of a vector
is the square root
of the sum of the squares.
So I have the length of v is
the square root of 4 x squared
plus 4 y squared.
OK.
Now, it gets steeper
and steeper, of course.
The cross-sections here
would be all circles
for this simple function.
And the gradients would
keep pointing out,
and we'd have a function that
comes from a surface like that.
OK, this is what I wanted to say
about question one, the meaning
of the gradient.
The thing to remember, if you
remember the two pictures,
you've really got
the idea of what
the gradient is telling you.
For a function of one
variable, the derivative
is telling you the slope.
Well, we've got slopes in the
x direction, slopes in the y
direction, and the
gradient direction
tells us the steepest slope.
And it tells us, yeah,
tells us what that slope is.
OK, so much for the
meaning of the gradient.
Now, backwards.
Suppose I have v.
Because these gradient
fields are extremely important.
I mean, they're
wonderful fields.
If you've got a v_1 and a v_2
that is the gradient of some u,
you want to know that.
I mean, that's good news.
Most fields will not.
So let's figure out, when is--
Can I lift that up now, and do
the other gradient thing now?
Or maybe I'll put the final
gradient blackboard here,
and then make way
for divergence.
OK, so I'm asking
now question two.
I'm given v_1 and
v_2, and I want
this to be du/dx for some u,
and I want this to be du/dy.
So I've got two equations.
If I'm looking for u.
Remember, I'm now starting
with these, looking for the u.
OK.
So, am I going to find Au?
Am I going to find a function
u, whose x derivative
is my v_1 that was given, and
the y derivative is my v_2?
Well, chances are not good.
Right?
I've got two equations
here, but only one unknown.
So generally, it's like
a rectangular system.
Usually there's no solution,
but sometimes there is.
So we have to find out, what's
the test for consistency
for these to have a solution?
And this brings us right
away to the key identity
from partial derivatives.
OK.
Can you see some
condition that has
to-- How can I connect
these two equations,
and therefore
connect v_1 and v_2?
That'll be the test for
weather-- You could say,
in matrix language, I'm
asking whether [v 1, v 2] is
in the column space
of the gradient.
Is it something I can get
from this tall thin matrix?
OK, they key idea is take the y
derivative of that equation, d
second u/dydx.
And take the x derivative of
this equation. dv_2 dy-- dx,
is the second derivative
of u, with respect
to-- the x derivative
of the y derivative.
OK.
So it's like I'm operating
on the equations.
I'm doing what
I'm allowed to do,
I'm doing the same thing to
both sides of each equation.
Now I'm going to eliminate.
And what am I going to find?
What's the key point here?
The key, key point
about second derivatives
is that that equals that.
Right?
Take any function.
Do we want to practice
with a function,
just to see it be true?
Take, let u be x cubed y.
Just for the heck of it.
OK, I don't know what--
Is that going to produce
anything interesting?
Then maybe I'd better
make it y squared.
I don't know why I'm doing this,
it just is like an example,
to make it believable.
OK, so du/dx, u_x, is --
and I'll often use u sub x
as a sort of shorthand
-- will be what?
3x squared y squared.
And u_y, taking the
y derivative is just,
x is constant, 2x cubed y.
And now let me do u_xy,
the y derivative of this.
Which is what?
It's been a long weekend,
but hey, we can do these.
The y derivative of that is
going to be 6x squared y.
And the x derivative
of this is going to be,
so I should say y-- I've
got the y derivative
and now I should take
the x derivative of that.
And what do I get?
The x derivative of
that is 6x squared y.
And look!
They're the same.
Hooray.
OK.
So if the function is smooth
and has these derivatives,
they'll come out the same.
And therefore, so
what do I conclude?
What's the test on v_1
and v_2 that it must
pass to be a gradient field?
For there to be a function u,
that solves these equations.
These are solvable
only when what?
Well, if these are the same,
these have to be the same.
So it's solvable only
when-- I need dv_2/dx -
dv_1/dy to be what?
Zero.
OK.
That's the conclusion.
Those have to be the same.
dv_2/dx - dv_1/dy
has to be zero.
OK.
Because those are the same.
I guess I came to this early
because it's the key identity
of vector calculus.
Well, the key identity
behind vector calculus
is this fact about
the derivatives.
Can I just throw out a question
that you might think about?
We already have seen, so often
now, the second derivative,
like v_xx.
Or u_xx, suppose.
So here's a little
question to think about.
So think.
OK.
I just want to bring
finite differences
in for a moment. u_xx
we've got a handle on.
We know that that's like u at
x+h -- and if there was a y,
put in the y -- minus 2u at x
-- and I can put in a y there --
plus u at x-h, y.
We've seen that.
That'll be the x derivative,
second x derivative-- sorry,
second x difference.
Since we're taking x
derivatives and x differences,
it's x that moves,
and y doesn't move.
Just the central idea
of partial derivatives.
u_yy will be similar
with y moving.
And my question to you is -- and
we could have asked it way way
back -- what's a finite
difference approximation
to u_xy, to the
cross derivative?
That equals what?
I want to go to
finite differences.
OK, what finite differences?
Which finite differences?
Maybe that's a question
to think about.
If I can remember,
I'll include it just
as a small homework question for
the homework on this material.
So that's looking
ahead, really, today.
We're not making
things discrete.
We're in continuous x and y.
We have vector fields.
And we now know the test
for a gradient field.
I'm tempted to use
the word curl here.
I'm tempted to
use the word curl.
I want to connect that test --
may I use the word curl without
-- and I'll say why I'm not
going to do everything properly
with curl right away.
I would describe this as curl.
The test is, the curl
of v has to be zero.
So for me, that's the curl of v.
You're going to
say, wait a minute.
I learned about curl, and that
doesn't look like the curl
to me.
So I'll say wait another minute.
It's not that far off.
OK, what's your objection?
Your objection is that the curl
is in three-dimensional space.
Right?
When you saw curl,
and of course it
comes in this
section of the book,
we had functions of x, y, z.
And the curl had
three components.
And those three components--
Do you remember curl?
I mean, if you remember
curl, you're a good person.
Because it's got
this-- You sort of
remember that it has
things like this.
Right?
Sort of, differences of
derivatives, and the indices
follow a certain pattern.
I'm saying that this
is the natural--
this is the curl in a plane.
What do I mean by
the curl in a plane?
So in 3-D, v has components
of v_1, v_2, and v_3.
Right?
That depend on x, y, z.
In the plane, in 3-D, I
have a vector field v, which
has components v_1, v_2, v_3.
All depending on x, y, z.
That's the general 3-D picture,
where you usually see the curl.
Now, in the plane,
what's happening?
In the plane, we
have two components.
So what's happening?
Think of this.
So in 3-D, our velocity
field is like, the flow
is going all over the place.
Right?
It's a three-dimensional flow.
But now suppose my flow
stays in the plane.
So in 2-D-- so now I have
to put 2-D up above here.
So in 2-D, a plane field is
what I'm working with today.
My v is some v_1(x,y).
No z, no dependence
on z. v_2(x,y),
the y direction of the
velocity doesn't depend on z,
because this is a plane
field, same on every plane.
And the third component
of this plane field,
the velocity perpendicular
in the z direction, is zero.
OK.
Zero.
So what I want to
say is that if I
look, if I specialize to plane
fields, to fields like these,
then the only component of the
curl that survives is this one.
See, the other components of
the curl, which I'm not even
writing down-- the other
components of a curl
have derivatives of
v_3, but v_3 is zero.
And they also have derivatives
of these guys with respect
to z.
But they don't depend on z.
So that's why all the
other pieces of the curl,
like, are automatically
zero for a plane field.
So that the only
component that's
significant-- The test curl
v equals zero boils down
to a test not on three
things, but just on one.
And that's the one.
So because I want to
stay mostly with plane
fields and
two-dimensional problems,
I just had to comment that, if
the curl was to get in here,
it would fit fine.
And if I restrict the curl to
the fields I'm working with,
plane fields, then there's
only one component I'll
have to think about,
it has to be zero
to have a gradient field.
OK, now I guess I should
just do an example or two.
Can I give you a
v_1 and v_2, and you
tell me, is it a gradient field
or is it not a gradient field.
Let me give you a different,
let me just change these guys.
Suppose I change
that to y and x.
So there is a v, a different
v. That's a vector field.
At every point x, y,
I've got a little vector.
I could try, even, to draw them.
And I'm going to ask you,
is it the gradient of any u.
And if it is, what's that u?
So let me show you what
I mean by a vector field.
I mean, at a typical point
like x=1, y=0, the vector--
Let's see, if x is
one and y is zero,
then what's the gradient at
that point? [0, 2], am I right?
I won't draw it too
big, or you won't
be able to see a darn thing.
OK, what about at
the point (1, 1)?
Which way is my vector
field going? [2, 2].
So what's that look like?
Plotting the vector field
v at a bunch of points.
So you get like a
map of little arrows.
So here it would go that way.
Is that right?
Huh.
I wasn't expecting
that, to tell the truth.
Let's see, so can I get
in some more points?
Let's see.
What if I have there.
What's-- At (1/2, 0).
Then, v is [0, 1].
Where is this flow going?
See, if the point is
along this line, where
y is equal to x, then the flow
was going out along this line.
Can you give me some
other point here,
just so we get some
handle on this?
There's the point
(2, 1), let's say.
Let me put it over a little bit.
How about the point (2, 1)?
What's the vector if
I just want to draw --
I'm just drawing here.
And of course, code would do
it much better than I'm doing.
(2, 1), that gives
me [2, 4], right?
So [2, 4] is over two
and up, it's like this.
I think -- but I
don't swear to it --
that if I connect
all this-- See,
now you have to take
a big leap of faith.
Imagine, like, at every point
we've got these little arrows,
and I want to connect them up.
Let me do something.
I'll do that, but let me
come back to the question
I should have asked you first.
Is this a gradient field?
Does it satisfy the curl zero
condition that we put in a box
here?
Does that satisfy dv-- There
is v_2 and there's v_1.
Is dv_2/dx, whatever that test
was, minus dv_1/dy equal zero?
Yes, no?
Yes, right? dv_2/dx is
two, and dv_1/dy is two.
So what's the conclusion then?
It satisfied my
little test, so this
must be the gradient of some u.
Right?
That's the question we have.
Which vector fields-- And we
found that this is one of them,
it passes the test.
It's the gradient of some u.
What's the u?
What's the function u,
which is supposed to exist,
whose gradient is that.
2xy.
Did everybody spot that one?
Because the x
derivative has to be 2y.
So I just integrate
with respect to x.
This is the x derivative.
It's 2y.
Take the integral with
respect to x, and I get 2xy.
And there could be some term
that depended only on y.
Anyway, this works.
I think that this, maybe
gives me somehow-- Oh, yeah.
What's the
equipotential curve now?
Oh, yeah, this picture's
going to come together.
What is the equipotential
curve for this potential?
It was a circle for the first
guy, but circles are out now.
I changed v. I've got a
new potential function.
And now I want to draw, in
this graph, the equipotentials.
Suppose u is one.
Suppose I draw the curve
2xy=1 in that picture.
What kind of a curve is it?
Do you recognize this?
The Greeks would.
Recognize 2xy=1.
Or you could say y=1/(2x).
That gives you a quick
handle on the curve.
It comes down like that.
Right?
And what's the Greek
name for that curve?
Oh, come on.
It's a hyperbola.
Hyperbolas-- You
remember the Greeks,
they had these conic sections.
They had ellipses, they had
parabolas, the marginal case,
and then they had hyperbolas.
And they all come from
second degree things.
If I have a x squared and 2bxy
and c y squared equal one,
that's one of those curves.
And if it was x squared
plus y squared equal one,
it was a circle.
If it was x squared plus
7y squared equal one,
it would be an ellipse.
The positive definite-- It all
comes down to linear algebra,
of course.
If that little matrix
is positive definite,
so that means a
and c are positive,
and ac is bigger
than b squared, you
know the test for
positive definite.
What kind of curve
do the Greeks have?
What kind of equipotential--
What kind of a curve have we
got here?
An ellipse.
If this curve, if
that little matrix
is indefinite, as,
for example, here.
So with this one, what would be
the matrix, what's the matrix
that goes with 2xy, if
I match this with this.
That's the matrix.
There's no a squareds,
there's no x squareds,
there's no y squareds.
And there are 2xy's, I
think the matrix is that.
So it's this nice
symmetric matrix.
Is that a positive
definite matrix?
Certainly not.
It's indefinite.
It's eigenvalues are
plus one and minus one,
adding to the trace zero.
So indefinite matrices
correspond to hyperbolas.
And later on,
definite matrices will
correspond to elliptic partial
differential equations.
And indefinite
matrices-- Like Laplace.
And indefinite matrices
will correspond
to hyperbolic partial
differential equations,
like the wave equation.
What's the-- Now we're here.
I didn't expect to get here.
What's the marginal case?
What's the marginal case
between positive definite
and indefinite is...?
Semidefinite.
Great.
And what kind of a
curve do you think
comes when this little
matrix is semidefinite.
It's the one in between
ellipses and hyperbolas.
The marginal guy is a parabola.
Right.
So semidefinite would
correspond to a parabola.
Right.
OK.
Good.
Anyway, all I was going
to say is, this u=2xy,
that's our potential.
If I draw equipotential
curves, they're hyperbolas.
And now, what's the point about
these little arrows that I got
started on.
What was the very first point
about the answer to the meaning
of the gradient was what?
These are the gradients of u,
so those arrows point where?
Perpendicular to the hyperbolas.
Perpendicular to the hyperbola.
We're trying to see the geometry
-- its beautiful geometry --
behind the gradient.
So if v is a gradient,
then it comes from some u.
I can plot the u equal
constant, the equipotential,
and then the gradients
will be perpendicular.
So they really are
a little-- OK, good.
OK, those are pieces
of information
that you have, but
always need saying again.
And to get the picture
in your mind-- I suppose,
finally, I should choose a
v which is not a gradient.
Just to finish.
How shall I adjust that v?
This v was a gradient.
Can you just change
it a little bit --
practically anything you
do will screw it up --
to make it not a gradient?
So I just changed this two,
what shall I change the two to?
To three.
That would totally foul it up.
So that vector field, which
I could draw little pictures
of, but there would be no
u that it's coming from.
There would be no u.
These little arrows would
not line up perpendicular
to some beautiful curves.
I don't get a u from that.
Because the y derivative
of that is three,
and it doesn't equal the
x derivative of that.
So that's a no-good one.
Let's go back to the good one.
OK.
OK, good.
Is that OK for gradients?
We got the meaning of gradients.
They point perpendicular
to equipotentials.
They tell how
steeply those-- They
tell the separation between
the equipotentials, right.
It's like, if you're
a mountain climber,
you're looking at your
map, your contour map,
and that's all I'm drawing here.
I'm drawing a contour
map that every guy who
goes climbing in New
Hampshire is going to have.
And it shows little circles,
those are level heights, right?
Those are level contours.
And if you want to climb
as fast as possible,
you go perpendicular
to those contours.
And the distance
between contours
tells you how steep it is.
So it's all nice geometry.
OK.
I've got to get to
divergence here.
Divergence.
I should have said
though-- Damn.
There's more to say
about gradients.
That question of whether
[v 1, v 2], the vector field,
is this question.
The question of is it
the gradient of some u.
So we now have a test.
We now have a test.
This is our test, right?
That's our test.
But I have to connect it
with Kirchhoff's voltage law.
Do you remember, we
haven't talked so much
about Kirchhoff's
voltage law, but I'm
connecting it with
the discrete case,
to add in a little more insight.
What did Kirchhoff's
voltage law say?
In that case, A was
a difference matrix.
It was the incidence
matrix for our graph.
And the question was-- I
have to take two moments
to think about that.
So Kirchhoff's voltage
law, for a graph.
A is an incidence matrix.
You know, the minus one, one
guys, one for every edge?
And let me call
it v again, or e.
I called it e at that time.
Let's just look at an x.
Right.
A is this long thin matrix,
times-- sorry, u's. u's.
Let me say it all at once.
Which vectors have the form Au?
Which vectors are combinations
of the columns of A?
The test is,
Kirchhoff's voltage law,
that if I go around any
loop in the graph --
so if I have a u_1 here, u_2
here, u_5 here, and u_7 here --
then Au will produce
u_1-u_7 on that edge.
It'll produce a
u_2-u_1 on that edge.
u_5-u_2 on that edge,
if the edges are
all going that way.
And it'll produce a
u_7-u_5 on that edge.
So I've got four components
of Au, four differences.
And what does Kirchhoff's
voltage law tell me
about those four differences?
Which I can certainly
see directly.
Those four differences, u_1-u_7,
u_2-u_1, u_5-u_2 and u_7-u_5.
What's the obvious fact
about those four guys?
They add to zero.
The total drop around
a loop is zero.
You see, if I cancel
those, if I add
them, the u_1's cancel, the
u_2's cancel, the u_5's cancel,
the u_7's cancel.
We know this.
OK.
So that's Kirchhoff's
voltage law.
It's got to have
a continuous form.
This tells me, this is
the test on v at a point.
What's the test on
v around a loop?
I just want to connect
that-- I have to connect that
to a second test.
I'll just mention it, and
you'll find it in the book.
That's the pointwise test.
That was the easy test.
We applied it to this and
we got the answer yes.
If it was 3y, 2x, we
got the answer no.
Now let me give you
a test that looks
like Kirchhoff's voltage law.
So I'm going to integrate
around a closed loop.
What am I going to integrate?
I think I integrate v--
Oh boy, I'd better look.
It's easy to get these wrong.
Yeah.
So I would call
this the vorticity.
And then I would
say the vorticity
is zero for a gradient field.
Now my integral guy is
going to be the circulation.
Oh yeah.
Because I'm following the path.
So it's just v_1*dx+v_2*dy
should be zero.
Around every closed loop --
that's idea of this thing,
that it tells me the integral
goes around a closed loop --
if I follow the velocity field,
the total circulation is zero.
I put this up here as a
fact in vector calculus
that's connected to that.
These, one is zero
when the other is zero.
There's a Stokes'
theorem that tells me
that this integral is found
from a double integral of this.
So if one is zero,
the other is zero.
I'm just saying, here
is the natural analog
of Kirchhoff's voltage law.
OK.
I had to say something
about voltage law,
because for the
divergence, which I'm now
going to get to-- Whatever.
Let me ask about
divergence of w equal zero.
What does that mean?
That's going to be the
equivalent of whose law?
Please tell me.
Which law is going to be the
equivalent of-- Divergence
of w equal zero is going
to mean there's no source.
Whatever goes in, comes out.
Whose law is that?
That's Kirchhoff again.
Well, yeah, other
people in physics.
Right.
But in our little world,
it's the other Kirchhoff law.
It's Kirchhoff's current law.
It's the one, it's the
A transpose, right?
This is what we're thinking of
as A transpose w equal zero.
Kirchhoff's current
law, in equals out.
How will I translate that
in equal out for functions?
Now I don't have--
On a graph, I just
had the total flow, the
net flow at every node.
Notice the divergence
is at every node.
The circulation was
around every loop.
OK.
So in equals out was just
the sum of four things.
OK, here I'm going
to have in equal
out-- How am I going to
express in equal out?
Divergence of w equals 0.
Yeah, what I need is
the divergence theorem.
Let's just face it,
we've got to have that.
So I have a region here.
I have a w everywhere,
w, [w 1, w 2].
Then the divergence theorem.
This is the great
identity, which
of course has a discrete form.
OK.
The divergence theorem says that
if I integrate over the region,
over this region
R, the divergence,
that's (dw_1/dx+dw_2/dy), dxdy.
So that's like
telling me the source,
I'm integrating over the
source at every point.
At every point here, this
measures in minus out.
But now, when I put the whole
thing together by integrating,
what's the right-hand
side of this equation?
Do you know the
divergence theorem?
And let's remember it
and see why it's so.
What I'm doing is in equals out
for the whole region at once.
Right?
When I-- This is like
in equal out at a point.
But now I'm putting all
the points together.
So the only way out will be
out through the boundary.
And so I'll need to
say how much flows out.
This is the total source, the
total in equal out inside.
The only way to get out
is through the boundary.
So this is the integral
around the boundary of-- So
what's the flow out?
It's, yeah, it's somehow--
Think now, what should go there?
This is flux I'm talking about.
Flux is short word for
the total flow out.
OK.
So now I've got
to get this right.
In vector notation, it would
be-- w tells me the flow.
But flow outwards, see,
suppose w points that way.
Then the actual flow
out is not all that.
Because a lot of that
is just going sideways.
It's this part.
It's the flow perpendicular
to the boundary.
So it's w dot n, the
normal component of flow.
And I integrate that
around the boundary.
There you have a
key, key theorem.
In 2-D. And it's an
equation for the flux.
It's like the fundamental
theorem of calculus,
but now we're in two dimensions.
And this is what it looks like.
OK, so I'm obviously not going
to finish with the divergence
theorem today.
So what's the conclusion?
If the divergence
is zero, then what?
If the divergence is zero, if
this is zero at every point,
then this is zero
across every loop.
Can I call this thing a loop?
That closed loop.
That's the conclusion
that we want to reach.
So this is the
divergence theorem.
The text gives a proof,
not to repeat in class,
but it's a crucial
formula to know.
That the integral of the
divergence is the flux.
OK.
Let's come back
to that Wednesday,
and I'll have lots
of homework for you.
Thanks for turning
in these today.